I'm Michelle battery from google based
in india for my friend agency I've just
seen a panelist on panel session talking
about social media typically in
education he was actually very
interesting they were hampered panelists
who had very deep knowledge on the
oxidation social media space and there
was a real discussion around around the
fact that most of information online
users are actually accessing leads into
the fire mobile and half of them I have
never actually used a desert on earth
which is which is pretty extraordinary
kids to develop markets where the
initial introduction to this year is
very muchly attacking them and remember
the other thing that was really
discussed was around around the
regulation of such as vinieron there was
a very good discussion around around
making sure the regulator's ashley's
look at things from from users
perspective rather than from from this
terrible government respect and also
that there's been a lot of research
recently that that social media it is
actually has beneficial impact on on
years rather than having negative
expecting it improves access to
information in constables community and
is generally sort of much more positive
than negative consequences whatever